sin recursos República democrática del
Congo se enfrenta al cólera
la organización médico Sin fronteras
hizo un llamado acerca de la rápida
propagación del cólera en el país
africano la cual ha causado más de 200
muertes y 12.000 casos sospechosos desde
principios de este año principalmente en
la ciudad de goma entre muchas otras
causas la falta de asistencia ha
impedido controlar el brote
no puedo decir que médicos Sin fronteras
tenga fondo suficientes pero intentamos
llevar camiones de agua para
distribuirla además estamos viendo como
multiplicar el número de letrinas que
hay en los sitios de desplazados
internos Así que no tenemos suficientes
herramientas para hacer frente
Durante los últimos meses miles de
familias han tenido que abandonar sus
hogares Y acomodarse en improvisados
campamentos como este
el grupo Rebelde m23 ha perpetuado
violentos ataques a la población civil
generando el desplazamiento de al menos
118.000 personas desde el 20 de octubre
según la ONU el cólera se contagia por
la ingesta de alimentos o agua
contaminados provocando diarreas
intensas Y deshidratación aunque existe
una vacuna para su tratamiento las
distintas cepas de la bacteria suponen
un reto aún mayor el niño Tenía diarrea
y estuvo vomitando toda la noche lo miré
Evi que estaba muy cansado sus ojos
comenzaron a hundirse en las órbitas le
pregunté a un vecino cercano donde está
el hospital pero no me pudieron ayudar
allí y me ofrecieron trasladarlo aquí
entre tanto las autoridades congoleñas
han hecho un llamado a la población a
estar atentos ante las amenazas
terroristas del grupo Rebelde m23
instaron a evacuar las zonas de mayor
riesgo